Dude, Michael Cain's in everything.
I literally could have picked a movie and it would have been, I mean,
he's in everything, dude. I mean,
he's even in Dunkirk as an uncredited voice, like,
are you kidding me all got a B in Dunkirk.
Is there a movie coming IO or is Michael Caine impression of all time
font I will ever
will ever that direct or that our work too.
If we out the dark night fond that if there's a spot I could fit in
there so bad. Oh,
Michael Kane has a website. That's hilarious. You know,
he literally had nothing to do with it.
Michael Kane has a website. Wow. The official website of sir Michael Kane.
First of all, if you're a ser dude, if I I'll never become a cer,
but if anyone ever anointed me and I became a
sir, and anyone ever called me, sir, Chris, Leah,
I'd say, Hey man, just call me Chris. Okay.
Dude, look at all the movies he's been in this guy, you know,
he doesn't give a about any of them too. Especially the later ones.
So funny dude, like he was in now, you see me too,
you know? And they're like, they're like, Hey Michael Kane,
uh, Z agents were like, do you,
will you feel like they want you to do all do it? No. Well,
this is the old do-it. Okay.
All right. Um,
they want you to fly to all Bo it auto CAD do AR
I'll do any movie you ever want me to do? Okay.
Zach Braff, uh, doing,
directing a movie called going and all though it Jose BRAF I'll do it.
He was in scrubs. What scrubs?
Although it scrubs a show on NBC, it was a big hit. Sam BC.
Oh, it was a, it was on TV. What's TV.
Uh I'll Bowie. They'll give you $19 million. I'll downcast.
I'll do it. Okay.
Hey, they're doing a movie called the Kingsmen.
Although it would you want to hear what it's about? No.
W they want to fly you to, uh, I'll do it. Hey. Hey,
they want, Hey, they want you to be an interstellar. Obviously I'll do it.
I feel like in scripts, it just says Michael Caine. It doesn't even,
and then they, and then they shoot it and then when they're shooting it,
they're like, Oh, let's have his name. Be Harry Brown. Let's have his name. Be
Hobbs. I mean, I just,
I turned on the prestige the other day. He's just, he's in that. Obviously.
Imagine having a movie called the prestige and Michael. Cane's not in it.
It's called the prestige agents. Yeah.
I heard there's a movie called the pre-stage. What?
A blow LM or not in it. Oh, well, we'll get I'll do it.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Just tell him, I'll do it. Well,
there's not a part for a guy your age RA at N
okay. He'll the guy said he'll write it in. No. Uh,
Michael Caine.
Hmm.
How, how much has honestly,
Michael Kane for real said like at this point,
how much has he honestly said what CNET,
how much has he honestly said that really? I,
I bet he said it seven times and I'm talking about when it first came out or
whatever, and it always just internet. And then they were like, Oh,
it's like a connected, a bunch of connected computers. And, um,
it's like a network and you can share like, uh,
communication and knowledge and all that. Oh, right.
And then like a week later he was like, yeah. You know,
I heard about this internet thing. What is it again?
And then that was his second time. And then they were like, Oh,
it's the thing where the computers are. And it's like, Oh, right, right. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I, uh, they set me up with an and, and uh,
an ALO L account. And he was like, no, it's AOL, RA, RA, RA.
And then somebody, uh, and then like three days later, uh,
he heard about AOL and he was like, Oh, is that that thing? That's um,
w w computers and they're like, what? And then, like, what was it cold?
And he's like the, the, the internet. And he's like, yeah, yeah. What is that?
And then he's like, Oh yeah, it's like the computer. And then like,
so he kinda knew what it was,
but then like a few years later he just stopped using it, you know?
Cause it was like 93 and he was like, just doing,
uh, Mr.
Destiny and noises off and the movie blue
ice and the Muppet Christmas Carol and, and,
and, and, and then,
and then, he did them in and then, and then,
and then he forgot and then someone was like, I'll email it to you.
And he was like, well, he's da. They were like, what's what?
And they're like email. And they was like, Oh, it's like a, I don't know,
do you have an AOL? And he's like, Oh yeah, I'll call [inaudible].
And they're like, no, it's AOL. And he's like, what would I call that?
And they're like, you mean the internet? And he's like, Hey, what is that?
And that was like the fourth time or third or fourth time.
And then it just happened a few, like a few years after that.
And then like the last time he did,
it was like in 2011 was like the seventh time.
Yeah.
Somebody was like, you know, you should get a website. I mean,
I know you have like, have great career everything, but like.
You know, the.
You know, it'd be cool. Like Gnomeo and Juliet is coming out.
And you're obviously a voice in that because they would never make that movie
without you doing the voice because there's somebody called Lord RedBrick in it.
So, you know, and you said,
you'll do it so before cars,
two goes into production because you're obviously going to play fin
missile. Again.
You should probably get a website. And he said, Oh,
like, it's.
It's a, you know, a homepage that you could have on the internet. And he said.
I swear to gods.
That happened seven times.
Well, every whatever helps, you know? And then they were like, yeah, well,
you can have things on there. Like, you know,
you have my Michael Kane news that people will go to.
And by this time it was like way too late for a
website anyway, because like, everyone has Instagram and like that.
And go back up, go back up and you'll have all the home for all your.
And you know, you have like, you go to the website, it'll be Michael caine.com.
And you have the Michael Kane news and you'll have Michael,
can you have like a biography about,
and then don't have a place to go for a filmography,
even though nobody will check it. Cause I am DB exists.
And then we'll have like a place where you can brag about like your
achievements. And he's like, Oh, Donald LA bragging. And it be like, no, well,
you don't actually have to do it. We'll do it. And then, you know,
we'll have like your,
your timeline and then there'll be cool because we'll be able to put your books
on there, which nobody even knows that you have. But you have obviously,
because you're 90 years old and you definitely wrote some books because you too
famous because people who are 90 years old and that famous,
obviously have a written books.
And then also we'll put up a gallery and we'll put your favorite pictures on
there.
And he says, and then,
and if you go to Michael Cain's gallery,
it's got
pictures in it,
go to Michael KAnsal website and go to,
he's got to
come on.
And one is of course of him in black and white,
because he's been alive since cameras existed.
Michael, can you send us your favorite pictures? I'll do it.
Can you send us your favorite pig? I'll do well.
I'll have two favorite pictures. Oh cool. Can you email it to us? Well,
nevermind. Just I'll come over and get them and scan them.
What scan and nothing. It's fine. You can get it through the internet or
I'm not going to ask what that is, but I think, uh,
I think on Noah is because that was the seventh time.
That was the last time he did it.
Oh.
Gallery, dude. How funny is it?
When somebody has a gallery on their website and it has two pictures,
one picture is a fear and then it's got different faces of him,
like throw out the years. But not really though. It's kind of only like, well,
I guess one is in his twenties and one's maybe now, now ish,
but then will the other ones of him getting his hair cut? Like what is that?
It's still from movie, I guess, right. Has to be,
Oh God who put this website together, dude,
Ray, Charles
Finn, missile. That's like so offensive,
you know? Yeah. We'll get Michael Kane to do it. Obviously.
Why that's fin missile? What is that? What couldn't be found?
Oh great.
Michael Kane has a thing on the bottom of his West side website that says useful
links and you click on it and it says, sorry, this page could not be found.
Uh. I'm sweating. I'm laughing so hard. Oh. That.
That is the hardest I've laughed on the website on the podcast website.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
I mean the movies this guy's been in And the movies,
the movies that sound like movies, he would be in are unbelievable.
The quiet American of course Michael Kane would be in that. The actors,
of course, Michael Kane would be in that second, second
Secondhand lions course. He'd be in that freedom of history of us.
Of course he'd be in that. Do it.
My producer is surfing around on this guy's website,
Michael Caine's website. And it literally,
I mean, what the? How is that? The quote? Okay.
So Michael Kane is called the elephant to Hollywood, by the way,
did he write this book? Maybe not whatever.
It's a book about him. It's an autobiography.
So we did all right. The quote.
You know, I like, there's a quote.
That's like the best book I've ever read or like one of the top
autobiographies of this generation. The quote that they're,
promoing this book to get you to want to read it. I, you're not on the,
on the website is, and I quote
of very British star,
a very British star.
What the is that his name? Oh my God.
His real name is well. Okay.
I mean, his real name is more British than fin,
missile and Lord,
whatever it was you could is his real name is so British.
You could put Lord in front of it and it would make it less British.
His name could be London, Manchester,
and it would be less British than this. This is his real name.
Maurice Mikel white.
It's been a long journey for Maurice Mikel, white,
born with rickets and London's poverty stricken,
elephant and castle to the bright lights of Hollywood.
The most British sentence of all time. Rick gets, you know.
Rick.
It's in London's poverty stricken, elephant and castle.
What is it? What is it?
Oh my God dude.
And the P the picture of him on this foe of him pointing
Michael Kane, the elephant to Hollywood,
the autobiography and the picture of him. Why would you, if you're Michael Kane,
why would you write a book? I mean, I understand people might want to read it,
but why do you give a? I don't understand.
I don't understand a very British star.
It's the thing that they have in quotes. What was the,
is that another book down there?
He wrote another book he wrote,
he wrote two autobiographies. Hey man, wait til later.
And the right only one.
And also this is the most British quote they're trying to preserve charm and
humor of natural Rick contour.
And guess if humor has a U in it,
Maurice Mikel white. You bet.
Look at how they try to make it. Oh, another one to come on, dude.
It's not autobiography. Thank God.
Oh, wow. Is there more? There's not more because I've got three books. Okay.
I mean, who gives a? These guys who write books? It's like it doesn't,
I don't understand. You make what? A million dollars, what?
This guy's got to have 35 houses.
I mean, what's he worth? Oh, cool.
He's worth $75 million. Cool. Hey,
you were seventy-five million dollars. Don't write a book. The,
dude, if I'm worth 75. No. How much of that is,
is his book $360,000 guarantee it. If that,
if that.